the consequences of these attacks thank
you mr chairman
thank you senator apartment uh mr blount
it is the practice of the homeland
security and government affairs
committee to swear in witnesses so
if you will stand and raise your right
hand please
do you swear that the testimony you will
give before this committee will be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
so help you god i do thank you you may
be seated
mr uh joseph blunt is the president and
ceo
of colonial pipeline he joined colonial
in october of 2017
with more than three decades of
experience
in the energy industry mr brown
previously served as ceo of century
midstream llc a company which he
co-founded
mr blunt has also spent 10 years with
unical corporation and ultimately
served as president and chief operating
officer of unical midstream in trade
mr brown welcome uh to the committee we
look forward to your testimony and
appreciate your willingness to answer
our questions you're recognized for your
seven-minute opening statement
chairman peters ranking member portman
and members of the committee
my name is joe blount and since 2017
i have served as the president and ceo
of colonial pipeline company
thank you for the opportunity to testify
before the committee today
since 1962 we have been shipping and
transporting refined products to market
our pipeline system spans over 5 500
miles and is one of the most complex
pieces of energy infrastructure in
america
if not the world on any given day we
transport more than 100 million gallons
of gasoline diesels jet fuel and other
refined products
shipping that product safely and
securely is what we
do the product we transport accounts for
nearly half the fuel consumed
on the east coast providing energy for
more than 50 million
americans americans rely on us to get
fuel to the pump
but so do cities and local governments
we supply fuel for critical operations
such as airports ambulances and first
responders
the safety and security of our pipeline
system
is something we take very seriously and
we always operate with the interests of
our customers
shippers and country first in mind
just one month ago we were the victims
of a ransomware attack
by a cyber criminal group in that attack
encrypted our
i.t systems although the investigation
is still ongoing
and we believe the attacker exploited
the legacy vpn profile that was not
intended to be in use
darkseid demanded a financial payment in
exchange for a key to unlock the
impacted systems
we had cyber defenses in place but the
unfortunate reality is that those
defenses
were compromised
the attack forced us to make difficult
choices in real time
that no company ever wants to face but i
am proud of the way our people
reacted quickly to isolate and contain
the attack
so that we could get the pipeline back
up and running
safely i am also very grateful for the
immediate and sustained support of law
enforcement
and federal authorities including the
white house
we reached out to federal authorities
within hours of the attack
and they have continued to be true
allies as we've worked to quickly
and safely restore our operations
i especially want to thank the
department of justice and the fbi for
their leadership
and the progress they announced earlier
this week
i also want to express my gratitude to
the employees at colonial pipeline
and the american people for your actions
and support
as we responded to the attack and dealt
with the disruption that it caused
we are deeply sorry for the impact that
this attack had
but we are also heartened by the
resilience of our country
and of our company finally i want to
address two additional issues that i
know are on your minds
and i'm going to address them the only
way i know how directly
and honestly first
the ransom payment i made the decision
to pay
and i made the decision to keep the
information about the payment as
confidential as possible
it was the hardest decision i've made in
my 39 years in the energy industry
and i know how critical our pipeline is
to the country
and i put the interest of the country
first
i kept the information closely held
because we were concerned about
operational safety
and security and we wanted to stay
focused on getting the pipeline back
up and running i believe with all my
heart
it was the right choice to make but i
want to respect those
who see this issue differently i also
now
state publicly that we quietly and
quickly work with the law enforcement in
this matter from the start
which may have helped lead to the
substantial recovery of funds announced
by the doj this week second
we are further hardening our cyber
defenses
we have rebuilt and restored our
critical i.t systems
and are continuing to enhance our
safeguards
but we are not where i want us to be if
our cio needs resources
she will get them we have also brought
in several the world's leading experts
to help us fully understand what
happened
and how we can continue in partnership
with you
to add defenses and resiliency to our
networks
i especially want to thank mandiant
dragos and black hills on the consultant
side
in the white house and all the
government agencies who assisted us both
with the criminal investigation
and with the restart of the pipeline we
are already working to implement the
recent guidance
and directives on cyber security
our forensic work continues and we will
learn more in the months ahead
i appreciate your support and look
forward to our discussion today
thank you mr brunt mr
um colonial is one of hundreds of
victims of ransomware attacks against
our nation's
critical infrastructure of this this
year
would you think uh and would you agree
with the statement that the federal
government
should be doing more to help companies
like yours
prevent cyber attacks thank you for the
question mr chairman
us first i'd like to state that as a
private entity we know we have a
responsibility as well
right we're accountable for our defenses
in in our reaction to
attacks like this but i think if we look
at the number of incidents that are
taking place today
throughout the world let alone here in
america it's private industry alone
can't can't do everything can't solve
the problem totally by themselves so
it's the partnership between private and
government
is very important to fight this ongoing
slot of cyber attacks around the world
cisa is the main federal domestic cyber
security agency
and it hosts the pipeline sector
coordinating council
to help bring together the private
sector and government in that
partnership as you mentioned to identify
and address
security issues do you know that if
colonial
ever participated in these meetings or
any other exercise
or events that were hosted by cisa
thank you for that question mr chairman
i i know that syste is a good
organization and i know that we maintain
a lot of
communication and contact with cisa and
have historically between our cio and
representatives from cisa
uh actually i was somewhat disappointed
when i heard that they felt like if we
hadn't gone in and contacted them the
first day
with the fbi that we would not have
contacted them separately
if you go back and look at the record
and look at who we contacted throughout
the event
we talked to every entity that could
possibly help us get through
the condition that we found ourselves in
that day
do you know if you participated in any
of those meetings uh
yes senator we we participate in every
governmental opportunity that we have to
do tabletop exercises security screens
and things like that
so you mentioned um uh the you didn't
contact sysa directly
uh and uh mike so
why did colonial pipeline decide to
forgo
contacting or notifying system directly
what was the rationale for that
thank you mr chairman we contacted the
fbi almost immediately that morning once
we
determined that we were under attack in
that conversation with the ip
fbi that morning they frankly said we
want to get on a phone call later today
we're going to bring sysa into the
conversation
and so at that point we already knew the
contact would be made there
we had a lot of governmental entities to
respond to that day
and call directly and that was the most
efficient means we knew they would be in
that meeting
and they were indeed in that meeting
right after noon the the day of the
seventh well as you mentioned uh in your
your opening uh
uh comments and you've reiterated here
and answers to these questions you've
been working
closely uh with the fbi uh and i know
you allowed
mandiant the private security firm which
you also referenced
in your opening to share information
with sysa that
is happening now but given the those
actions i i would suspect that
that you agree that you have a
responsibility to protect other
potential victims
based on on what you have learned to
what extent do you believe that
responsibility
extends uh thank you for that question
mr chairman
we've been very transparent from the
start if you if you looked at who we
contacted that day we started with the
fbi
obviously they included in the follow-up
conversation
and then we started marching through all
the ones that we normally would report
to whether it's the ferc
fimsa you know doe
et cetera et cetera and what we found
during the that day was that we were
allowed the conduit through
doe to talk to all these organizations
on an ongoing basis but through one
central briefing so we found that the
ability to have that conduit to work on
the supply side of the equation
and on the restoration side of the
equation with any number of governmental
entities was extremely helpful to us and
then of course on the investigative side
we had the fbi insist on working on that
so for anybody that comes under an
attack like this
what you can't recreate is time and
space
and the ability to respond and so the
ability to have the conduit both on the
investigative side
as well as on the restoration and on the
supply side was extremely helpful to
colonial pipeline and our employees
it was all hands on deck uh situation
that morning and throughout the event
and and prior uh to the the attack uh i
assume
i know you're not a technical expert but
it's uh it would have been helpful
for you to get information about other
potential attacks or other companies
that may have been attacked with uh
similar uh types of
cyber cyber incidents yes mr chairman
for example we gave a lot of indications
of compromise to the fbi insisted
during the days of the event and i think
what we saw
is as an industry is immediately that
material is dispersed out and in the
case of the ip addresses i believe cisa
actually posted those
and that was a means for us once again
to efficiently communicate
to our industry partners what was going
on and in addition to that
we go back to the first day when we were
contacting people we made initial
contact with some of our industry trade
groups to tell them
what we could possibly tell them at that
point in time so we've been once again
very open and transparent
hoping that everybody could could not
only be aware of the situation but think
about what they could do to help
prevent that from occurring in their own
company
well that's all very encouraging to hear
and uh just uh for the record where
we're working i'm working on legislation
right now to
make sure that information is indeed
being shared with sysa to get a better
understanding of what's happening in
ransomware
not just with your company but across
the across the board
uh reporting indicates uh and you've
affirmed
today that you made the decision uh to
uh to pay the ransom of
four four four point four million
dollars uh we're certainly happy to see
that
that's a portion of that's being
recovered by the department of justice
now
my question to you though is prior to
making the decision to pay the ransom
had you consulted with anyone in the
federal government
on whether that would be an appropriate
response
thank you for that question mr chairman
it was our understanding that
that the decision was solely ours as as
a private company to make the decision
about whether to pay or not to pay and
considering the
the the consequences of potentially not
bringing the pipeline back on as quickly
as i possibly could
i chose the option to make the ransom
payment in order to get all the tools
necessary
and the optionality of those tools to
bring the pipeline on
as quick as we possibly could safely as
well as securely well after you
paid the the ransom and received the key
to unlock your systems
did that actually fix all of the the
problems where are you today and
uh how long do you think it'll take for
you to be
100 that's a great question mr chairman
thank you for asking it
um i think what a lot of people don't
realize about cyber attacks and the
repercussions of a cyber attack is it
takes months and months and months and
in some cases what we've heard from
other companies that have been impacted
years to
to restore your systems our focus that
first week
was to restore the critical systems that
we needed on the it
side in order to safely and securely
bring our pipeline system back up
so that's what we focused on you know an
example would be this week we're
bringing back online
seven finance systems that we haven't
had
since the morning of may 7th so again
the remediation is ongoing and again
that's why you bring someone like a
mandy
and immediately one to help investigate
the situation
but also to help restore what you've
lost
throughout the process the keys are
helpful and we have used the keys
so they have been advantageous to us but
they're not perfect
and i think it's important to remember
you get the keys but you still have a
problem for
many months and a lot of work to do yes
sir that really illustrates the
seriousness of what we're dealing with
thank you for your answers ranking
member portman you're recognized for
your questions
thank you chairman so mr blunt you're a
victim and we understand that and yet
you know we're trying to provide
oversight and even provide some new laws
potentially
to try to deal with this increasing
and really dramatic issue of cyber
attacks
and specifically today talking about
ransomware let's just
clarify that the record you made your
ransomware
uh payment to the hackers on the day you
discovered it is that correct
ranking member uh thank you for that
question we did not we made the decision
that evening
to negotiate with so that was the
evening of may 7th
yes sir and so you didn't make the
payment until when
the payment was made the following day
may 8th yesterday
and you indicated today that the fbi was
uh
in discussions with you on may 7th is
that correct
um ranking member portman that's correct
yes sir
and what did the fbi tell you what did
they
advise you to do with regard to paying
the ransom
ranking member portman i believe i was
not involved in those conversations with
the fbi but in discussions with my team
i don't believe the discussion about the
ransom
actually took place the first day on may
7th
the focus more was on getting to the
proper centers of expertise with the fbi
and in this case i believe it was the
san francisco office we started with the
atlanta office and our
notification and then it was a function
of starting
they already started to collect data
from us you know indications of
compromise
so their official position is uh you
shouldn't pay ransoms and yet they
didn't communicate that to you as far as
you know
ranking member portman of course i was
not in that conversation i can't confirm
or deny that i
but i do agree that their position is
they don't encourage the payment of
ransom
it is a company decision to make yeah
and so you
you knew what their advice was going to
be even page and provided
that day ranking member portman yes sir
we did
okay did you talk to the treasury
department's office of foreign assets
control this is the office that's
charged with sanctions and so if you're
a sanctioned individual and you make
a payment as you know the potential
violations of law
did you contact treasury department's
office of foreign assets control
ranking member portman that that day
that we decided to
um negotiate we hired experts both on
the legal side as well as on the
negotiation side we didn't have any
direct contact with darkseid ourselves
and i can assure you that everyone
involved in that process continually
went and back checked to make sure that
this was not an ofax listed
entity so you were in touch with ofac to
ensure you weren't paying the ransom to
a sanctioned entity or to a sanctioned
individual
ranking member portman i was not
involved in those conversations and and
so i can't
attest to who actually talked to who but
i do know
that repeatedly throughout the process
the
the fact of whether darkseid was on the
sanctions list or not was
fact check repeatedly okay we made some
follow-up questions on that just to
figure out
um what the relationship was there and
again
this is about looking forward how do we
avoid
the situation where sanctioned
individuals or entities are getting a
ransom payment
which would be a violation of federal
law the wall street journal says that
the decryption tool
didn't really work so you paid the
ransom they give you
the decryption tool to be able to undo
the harm that they did
that's how it normally works uh and yet
the decryption tool
was not effective is that correct
ranking member portman
the the encryption tool is an option
that's made available to you
so and when you're looking at bringing
critical structure back up as quickly as
you possibly can
you want to make every option available
to you that you you can
mandy it can be the best one to answer
about how important the encryption tool
was
restoring the critical options we needed
within
the first did they did the decryption
tool work it has worked yes sir
so so the wall street journal story was
inaccurate it was effective
ranking member portman i think that
article came out pretty early on so i
would say that we know
subsequently that the encryption the
encryption tool actually does work to
some degree as i
as i've stated uh earlier it's it's not
a perfect tool
okay it was provided to you by the
hackers correct ranking member portman
yes sir
that's correct so there's also news
reports about
how this happened uh as i said i'm
opening statement there was a compromise
password
of a virtual private network or a vpn
account
this account apparently did not use
multi-factor authentication which again
is kind of just a basic
cybersecurity hygiene item that you know
companies should have in place
making it harder for people to gain
access prior to the attack did your
company require all employees to use
multi-factor authentication
ranking member portland in in the case
of this particular
legacy vpn it did only have single
factor
authentication it was a complicated
password so i want to be clear on that
it was not
a colonial 123 type password the
investigation is ongoing by mandate to
try to determine how that material
was compromised but in our
normal operation we use an rsa token
allowance in order to create
authentication difficulties for remote
access
so would your advice going forward be
that multi-factor authentication ought
to be used
ranking member portland that's
absolutely the correct advice so tsa has
given uh
industry a lot of leeway critical
infrastructure and and and
voluntary compliance is uh has been the
approach
they came out late last month after
your attack with some new directives and
now there's a mandate that reporting
cyber attacks
uh must happen they must go to cisa
which is again this
group within the urban homeland security
and then will be shared with tsa you've
got a designated cyber security
coordinator within the company and you
have to review your current activities
against their recommendations on
cyber risks uh identify gaps and develop
remediation measures do you support that
ranking member portman if you look at
our actions starting on may 7th we
almost to the t duplicated what the new
standards are and we are in full
compliance today as well
yeah so i mentioned earlier that you
know we have
written legislation in this committee
over the years to try to deal with cyber
security
pretty much every member here today has
been involved with that um
and i said earlier we obviously need to
do more the question is
with regard to critical infrastructure
in particular should there be more
mandates
and now there is and they have the
authority to do this under 2007 law
it appears now there is this mandate on
reporting it a mandate on
having a coordinator but still there's
not a mandate saying
that you you have to do certain things
in terms of best practices or good cyber
hygiene
do you think there should be additional
requirements from tsa with regard to
critical infrastructure
ranking member portman first i'd like to
thank you for your leadership
on these issues in the past but
certainly on a go forward basis
i think anything that can help industry
have better security practices uh
standards to follow
would be extremely helpful especially
for the smaller companies that are
that are in other industries as well as
my industry less sophisticated
thank you chairman thank you senator
portman senator carper you are
recognized for your questions
great thanks uh thanks mr sherman mr
thank you very much for
joining us uh we got that that you and
your employees your company and those uh
who've been uh certainly consumers have
been
armed by this but we were glad that if
you uh
just had the opportunity to speak to uh
to other people your counterparts and
businesses around the country maybe
given two or three words of advice
uh to help them avoid this sort of thing
what would you say
senator that that's a great question and
if i could boil it down to two or three
words of advice as you suggested
i would i would suggest that we
certainly take a look at our defenses
and even though we felt comfortably
historically that were where we
felt we needed to be to protect our
assets uh this
this threat grows every day the
sophistication of this threat grows
every day
so uh let's make sure that we're we're
keeping our eye on that
and then the other side of the equation
is if if you
wind up in a situation like we found
ourselves on may 7th
have an emergency response process that
allows you to respond quickly
and most importantly to be extremely
transparent and to contact the
authorities
who indeed do have resources that
potentially could help you
through a very very difficult process
thank you oh abraham lincoln was once
asked
what is the role of government and he
responded
to all the government has to do with the
people what he cannot do for themselves
and uh with respect to uh one of the
things i've been on this committee for
20 years and uh we have uh spent a lot
of time trying to figure out what is the
role of government especially with
respect to cyber security
but uh i'm a question saying what uh
what do you believe that the role the
appropriate role for government
uh is should be should have been how do
we measure up
what that what did we do well or what
could we have done better
thank you senator thank you thank you
for that question
obviously with the threat that we have
uh in this country and around the world
today
i think the private public partnership
is extremely important
we can do things as private industry to
protect our facilities
in in assets and base safe uh and cyber
security wise but there are things
around the world that we obviously have
no ability to participate and that's
pressure on foreign governments harbor
criminals and
and and people like this and and that's
where government comes into play
as a company that's been regulated for
over 57 years regulation is not foreign
to us
and we think regulation can be healthy
uh
and so we we support anything that helps
further protect these critical assets
that we all rely upon for our daily life
well as you um i'm sure you know there
are
numerous government agencies that are
involved in trying to secure critical
infrastructure of all kinds of
infrastructure specifically
on pipelines today the transportation
security administration is in charge of
federal problems for pipeline securities
but tsa
most people think tsa is going through
the airport going through airport
security but they do
a lot of other things for the most part
to them do not think very well
but the tsa works closely with the
department of transportation's
pipeline and hazardous materials safety
administration as well as folks of the
department of energy and the federal uh
energy regulatory commission
then that's just a handful of government
agencies that are working
to secure our nation's pipelines and
that type of coordination
among agencies requires continued
collaboration and communication
got a two-part question for you if i
could first how frequently
are you or your counterparts or your
your team members
uh how frequently are you in contact
with these government agencies i
mentioned
about and secondly how has interagency
coordination among these agencies
strengthened
or weakened pipeline security
thank you for that question senator uh
we're in contact
quite often with all the agencies that
you mentioned again as i noted we are a
regulated entity
uh and we know it's important to
communicate what's going on across our
pipeline system and with our operations
with all our
our governmental partners and then there
is a lot of entities within the
government that that don't regulate us
like cesa up up to may 7th
that we also have had constant
communications going on so i know from
my cio's perspective
she does spend a lot of time with sisa
she does spend a lot of time with
uh the tsa uh talking about what's going
on in the cyber space and defenses and
things like that
and and i'll go back to may 7th and what
what i saw as being most helpful for an
operator that's been
you know subject to an attack is again
that was critical
for us to be able to have that one
central conduit in the government and in
this case it was doe
who allowed us to communicate everything
that was going on
at the time through one central conduit
although all the parties that you
mentioned were sitting at that table
virtually of course because of covid
hearing material
real time that could help them go about
doing their job
or potentially could go about helping
the market resolve the issue that we saw
so we saw a lot of permitting changes
allowing truck drivers to drive longer
hours allowing trucks to carry more fuel
that was the kind of coordination that
we got through that central conduit that
the white house
gave us and again i'm not i'm not saying
one entity over the other i'm saying
that the combination of all of them
through that central conduit was
extremely valuable to our response
extremely valuable to the american
public to get as much fuel back into the
system as we possibly could
and whether that's through deviations
and regulations
or things that allowed us to bring our
pipeline on much sooner
than perhaps would have been right
um but maybe one
one one other question how quickly uh
did your company reach out to the fbi
senator great question we reached out to
the fbi within hours
within hours
and was responsible the response
uh senator was we want to get you back
on a phone call we're going to bring
system into the conversation
and we're going to start going through
it and i think part of that was we
called the atlanta office
and in this particular case they felt it
was dark side and the fbi has an office
specifically dedicated they call it a
center of excellence for dark side so
they're dark side
experts which are california based so
again as early as we called in the
morning
i mean i i know the f fbi probably
responds
uh regardless of the hour of the day it
was pretty early in california when we
made our call to the atlanta office
but great response on the part of the
fbi
how about the response from assistant
that'd be my last question how about the
response assistant
uh senator of course i wasn't involved
in those conversations but what i saw as
a result of cisa being involved in those
conversations was the ability to take
some of the
some of the forensic evidence that the
fbi was comfortable seeing released to
the public
wind up in citizen notifications that
would then help
light companies and certainly a lot of
pipeline companies take a look at like
ips addresses and things like that
that we had shared during that phone
call and get that out in memo form to
other operators so great
sharing of information on the part of
cisa
thanks very much for joining us good
luck thank you sir
thank you senator carper uh senator
johnson you're recognized for your
questions thank you mr chairman
i want to start out by again emphasizing
pointing out that
you were the victim of a crime
you're not the bad guy here and i
appreciate my colleagues i pretty well
acknowledge that as well and
i think that's been reflected in their
line of questioning
i want to because a lot of people can do
monday morning quarterbacking and it's
easy for
federal agencies to say you know don't
pay ransoms because it just encourages
more
but i just kind of want you to for the
record lay out
how much worse could have it been had
you not made that very difficult
decision to
kind of bite the bullet so that you
could get your pipelines back up and
operational
uh senator first thank you thank you for
your kind words and and thank you for
your question as well
that's an unknown we probably don't want
to know and it may be an unknown that we
don't want to play out in a public forum
but if you start to look at the fact
that
it took us from friday all the way to
wednesday afternoon the following
and we already started to see
pandemonium going on in the markets
people doing unsafe things like filling
you know garbage bags full of gasoline
or
people fist fighting in line at the uh
the fuel pump the concern would be
what would happen if it is stretched on
beyond that amount of time right what
would happen
uh at the airports where we supply a lot
of jet fuel
let alone what might happen to the gas
pump my concern the first day was more
to the first responders and the
ambulances and
in the things that we count on in
emergencies beyond our own current
emergency
that was my concern that first day so
again our focus and our team's focus
regardless of what type of threat we
see is to identify the threat contain
the threat remediate
and restore and that goes beyond just
you know an incident like that that's
about
anything that we see as unsafe and
that's why the call that morning
by that com head controller supervisor
the control room to shut the pipeline
down
was so critical okay again
i mean that's an appropriate response
and i'll leave it to people's
imagination but i want people thinking
about that as well
yes sir cyber attacks are an ongoing
problem
there's no easy solution as you say in
your testimony the the
criminals are on the offense and they
have a huge advantage
and it doesn't take much in terms of
vulnerability you know no matter how
strong your i.t systems are your cyber
security systems are
their vulnerabilities and they get
exploited and these keys becoming more
and more
susceptible to this in terms of
government versus private sector you
know from my standpoint i think cis is
very valuable from the standpoint of
sharing information preemptively
trying stop some of these things you
know we've heard in testimony 90 of
these attacks
can be prevented just by basic cyber
hygiene it certainly sounds like you had
pretty pretty sophisticated cyber
hygiene although obviously
vulnerabilities
the federal government can hold nation
states accountable
that allowing these cyber attackers to
operate on their their foreign soil
and then of course hold them accountable
when something happens
but also helping recovery recovery in
law enforcement
uh i'm not convinced that federal
government is going to be particularly
effective at
issuing standards and keeping them up to
date so
i really looked at the private sector
being far more more
nimble at that one of the processes i've
proposed is using a private sector model
like an isil certification you know i
imagine you go through something like
that
you know i did you have six-month
surveillance audits you tie that to
uh insurance uh system as well where
your rates are based on
how good you achieve the standards i
mean that's that's the system that will
be as nimble as the private sector be is
up to date
uh be able to employ the absolute best
cyber security experts which is one of
the problems with the government i'm not
again it's just it's just a problem you
know government can't pay
to retain the absolute best talent
across the board
i just kind of want your thoughts on on
that type of framework
public versus private senator thank you
and i think those are all very good
thoughts i think again we have an
obligation
as private entity to make sure that our
systems are as capable as they possibly
can be
and we have a responsibility to continue
to look at those systems because as we
all know
the threat continues to evolve the
sophistication of the players continues
to evolve their
their ability to to uh compromise
systems
uh continually evolves and i think in
common in combination with the
government
together combined we have a much better
ability
as americans to thwart the threat
of cyber attacks uh and i think that
again we both have a responsibility you
you shared the the concept of
private industry can't do things to
foreign governments can't put pressure
on foreign government
that's extremely important here if we
look at where these criminals are housed
right that something needs to be done
there so again i think that
private public partnership is very
valuable
but we certainly know we have
responsibilities and accountability as
well
again i'm concerned about the
government's a capability
of establishing the standards then again
penalizing businesses for being victims
of crime if you don't meet their product
probably in many cases out of date
standards so i
i would proceed down that line with
caution just real quick
were you a member of an isac
an information sharing and analyst
analysis center
for your industry senator i i don't
actually know the answer to that if i
can get back to you
okay i'd appreciate that and the final
question i have is
uh in our briefing and news reports it
wasn't just the
the shutdown the ransomware but as you
know prior to them shutting you down
they
extracted all kinds of data that
apparently they
tend to reveal or not reveal can you
just describe that if if possible
because i'm i mean
intrigue is maybe the wrong word but i i
i thought that was
quite interesting and do you have any
assurances did you get that data back uh
was that part of the the ransom deal
that that won't be disclosed
and can you kind of tell us what kind of
data they're talking about why that even
be valuable for them
or hurtful for that to be disclosed
senator very
very good question very important
question as part of the ransomware note
they tell you that they've encrypted
information uh that they've exfiltrated
information so
we knew that they had exfiltrated
information uh we worked very closely
with the fbi on that
and the fbi is probably the best entity
to respond to that since they're still
you know investigating the situation and
you know getting closer apparently to
uh at least we hope to to the
perpetrators themselves
but would that be personal information
from your employees that would be
valuable or just trade secrets uh i mean
your public company so the financial
information is available i'm just kind
of wondering what
what threat that represents to your
entity or or to your employees
senator uh you know what we know about
that material right now is
it it was exfiltrated off the share
drive
so it contains a lot of different type
of material uh the good news is
it was retrieved very quickly it was
brought back in
uh and again i think the fbi can talk a
little bit more about that then i feel
comfortable right now because of their
investigation
um but but uh again that the fact that
was retrieved very quickly is helpful
we don't fully understand everything
that's in it because of where it's
it's been held since it was retrieved uh
but
we have people obviously involved in the
combined process who have been looking
very closely at that data
okay listen i appreciate you coming in
here and being so as forthright as you
become so thank
you thank you senator thank you senator
johnson uh
senator hassan you are recognized for
your questions
well thank you chair peters and thank
you ranking member portman
for this hearing today and thank you mr
bump for being willing to come before
the committee today
cyber security is a collaborative effort
to be sure and we need to work together
to strengthen public and private cyber
defenses
mr blount i was glad to see that u.s
authorities were able to deprive hackers
of millions of dollars in expected
ransom
however i want to better understand your
decision to pay the ransom and i
understand it was a difficult decision
as you've already discussed the fbi and
other federal agencies
strongly discourage paying ransom
because it incentivizes more people to
become cyber criminals
and to develop better ransomware tools
when you decided to pay the ransom did
you know how much of your network was
affected at the time
thank you for that question and good
morning again good morning um
no we did not and and i think that's
what a lot of people don't understand
in these incidents uh these attacks it
takes you days
basically to see into your your system
that's been corrupted
as to what you have what's what's
potentially been exfiltrated
uh in the case of colonial we had really
good backups
is what i've been told by mandate uh but
it still took them days to get through
those backups so when we look at our
response time and ability to bring this
system back up
it was fairly good in in reality
my concern was you don't have that view
at all
for days and when you have a critical
asset like this
right you've got to focus on what is the
best
opportunity of options you have in front
of you to take take avail of
and in that case it was to get the
encryption tool and to get our
information back
okay so i wanted to follow up um
you mentioned the federal agencies um
that you reached out to but what if any
outside of those agencies non-federal
entities did you consult with were there
private firms that you consulted with
yes senator great question obviously we
we talked to mandiant yeah i talked to
mandian about that we talked to our
legal resources that have been
involved in any number of cyber cases in
the u.s over the last couple of years
people that have had real time
experience with these criminals
as well as the specific science of cyber
attacks and compromise so yes a lot of
conversation went into that
that that decision that i made sure to
negotiate
okay and did you have a cyber security
response plan
in place prior to the attack and if so
did it
include any guidance about paying a
ransom
senator great question what we have as a
pipeline operator and it would be not
unique necessarily to us or colonial so
we have an emergency response process
right and again i said earlier this
morning
see the threat contain the threat
remediate the threat
and restore so in this case you use the
same
process but you use a different set of
experts so in this case
we reached out immediately to fbi
because it was criminal right
uh we immediately uh reached out to
legal resources that have dealt with
this
we immediately reached out to mandiant
right but my question is
in your planning did you have a plan
for cyber security response that
included guidance about ransomware
senators specifically no no
discussion about ransom and action to
ransom
and and did did your team do tabletop
drills for instance to go through an
actual simulated cyber attack before
this happened
senator yes we do participate in those
with various various groups as well as
do them
on our own at colonial okay
some private sector companies can focus
strictly on economics and perform
traditional cost-benefit analyses
without having to consider national
security concerns
however owners and operators of critical
infrastructure and i appreciate
your comments this morning acknowledging
that colonial overseas critical
infrastructure
that carries a heightened obligation and
duty to be capable of delivering goods
and services
to citizens all um in this case up and
down the east coast
mr colonial pipeline surely performed
some number of cost-benefit analyses
regarding the operation of its pipeline
to determine how much to spend on
pipeline hardware
personnel and even cyber security did
any of your analyses incorporate any
public responsibility factors
such as the impact of a potential cyber
attack on consumers
or on the u.s economy senator that's a
that's a great question
i i wouldn't say that we approached it
that way we know our number one goal
at colonial is to safely and securely
operate that pipeline
because we've known for 57 years the
importance
of that pipeline to the well-being of
the american citizen
so that's always been our focus our our
investment whether it's in
uh pipeline integrity right or whether
it's in in
cyberware and i.t is all derived around
keeping safe and protecting the asset
because of what its main benefit is to
united states
okay i understand that and i appreciate
that answer but you know
as you've had conversations with other
senators this morning
you've mentioned that you didn't have
two-step authentication in place you've
mentioned a legacy vpn which in
my understanding means it was a pretty
old vpn
so i don't think it's acceptable to
understand
the critical nature of your of your
product um
but then not really have uh the
preparation and the system in place
to protect it as if it's critical
infrastructure you really do have
an obligation to us communities that you
serve and to consumers into our national
security
so um i am concerned that it doesn't
seem to have been a formal factor
in your analysis of how how much to
strengthen your systems
senator we we take cyber security very
seriously
i i did reference earlier that the vpn
was a legacy vpn
we could not see and it did not show up
in any pin testing that that's
unfortunate
uh but again the safety and security of
the system is highly critical we've
never
never had our board uh deny us any funds
associated with safety and security
whether it's on the i.t side or the
physical side of the pipe
if my cio wants funds she gets them okay
i would just
in and this is an issue that i think
we're seeing across the board on cyber
we need to start imagining what can
happen and respond accordingly as
opposed to always be looking at what the
last problem was right
um and really investing and for critical
infrastructure
i think it's absolutely important that
we have standards that really
uh make sure that companies are
investing
uh in the kind of infrastructure they
need um i have
another question i am running out of
time so i'll submit it for the record
but i really would like uh to get your
thoughts
about what kind of information
public-private
um information sharing needs to happen
um between and among whom and at what
level because i think that's another
important piece to this whole issue
thank you very much for being here this
morning thank you mr chair
thank you uh senator hassan for your
questions uh the chair recognizes
senator lankford for your question
saying mr chairman
schmon thanks for being here there is no
ceo in america that wants to be sitting
in the same chair you're sitting in
right now uh to be able to go through
all this you're a month past
a major attack uh obviously there's a
lot of work that you're going through
can i'm
back up for colonial when is the last
time the colonial
that pipeline was down and not providing
fuel to the east coast
uh senator that's a great question that
pipeline has
never been down completely with the
exception of i
and i learned that just this week over
the couple hours of y2k and we can all
appreciate going back in time that we
were all concerned about the clock back
then
uh so you know periodically from time to
time we'll have
portion of the system down during a
hurricane event or something like that
but never the entire system at one time
and never for that
obviously that duration of time i i
think we as americans
get so used to going to the gas pump and
filling up with refined products
every one of us has landed at charlotte
airport
and um jet a has been added to our plane
as we change planes there uh we get so
used to that we lose track of some of
these things so
i i want to ask a couple of things here
you had to do a physical inspection
and a cyber inspection of this pipeline
we're just going through the digital
portion of it it just
has to do some physical inspection as
well yeah great great question
so you know in the early hours of may
7th we didn't know exactly what we had
we had the ransomware
but again we're always concerned about
the the security of the pipeline
and and you may have read in the press
as a factual statement we drove
over 29 000 miles of the pipeline and
again remember it's only a 5500 mile
pipeline
so we had constant ground surveillance
in addition we also fly the pipeline
it's offensive regulation that we fly
the pipeline
we fly in excess of that regulation on a
normal basis
and on top of that evil even doubled up
our efforts during this point in time
again
we didn't know that it was just the
cyber attack we had to make sure that it
wasn't potentially an attack on our
physical structure as well
so that was completed there were no
other physical damage that that you
could identify
that is correct senator we didn't see
anything we did keep an eye obviously on
the pipeline this year where
we kept the pipeline under pressure and
that would allow us to bring the
pipeline up much quicker so we had
people
manually in the field looking at gauges
the old school way of watching pipeline
pressures
to make sure that we were in compliance
with all the regulations regardless
of the attack and what happened in the
shutdown so i said to several people
that i've talked to in the last month uh
when we saw suddenly gas lines appearing
and a pipeline go down
at this point that everyone learned the
importance of pipelines if if i rewind
two months before that all the
conversation was about
you know slowing down permitting new
pipelines maybe we're not going to do
pipelines at all
make it harder to be able to do
maintenance on federal lands on
pipelines
that two months ago the conversation was
well maybe we need fewer pipelines and
maybe we need to make this harder to be
able to develop new pipelines
obviously keystone pipeline was in the
news to say we're just not going to do
that at all
and so products coming out of canada and
out of montana are just going to find
trucks and trains to be able to get
there
i'm not going to ask you this same
question because that's not going to be
fair to you but i've told a lot of folks
what we watched happen with the sudden
shutdown of a pipeline is it goes to
christmas future for the entire country
if we don't continue to maintain our
pipelines
increase capacity of pipelines if we
don't continue to
expand and have a duplication of
pipelines
in spots to be able to make sure we have
redundancy for this
pipelines are essential to america the
two and a half million miles
of pipelines that we have scouted around
the country we lose track of how
incredibly important they are
so i'm grateful that your company's had
such a good reputation
this is terrible to be a victim of a
ransomware attack
and there's something that you have that
every ceo in america would like to hear
and that is what are the lessons learned
on cyber issues that you've already
identified obviously your team's taken
on
the number ones already come out looking
for legacy entries into your system
that don't have two two-factor uh
authentication on it
what else has been identified that you
need to be able to take on to pass on to
others
thank you for for your question again i
think the most important thing is
to to not be complacent about what you
have because of the pace of change on
the outside from the criminal side
and then the secondary to that equally
as important
is the ability in to have an emergency
response process
in place if we had not been trained for
the last 57 years to respond to
any threat whatever that threat is it's
a it's an extension cord on the ground
that hasn't been taped down that someone
might trip over and hurt themselves
if we hadn't been trained like that and
our employees hadn't been trained by
that
who knows how many days it potentially
could have taken to bring the asset back
online
we know the importance of the asset
we're dedicated the american public as a
as a result of all training and
everything we've done through the years
to
to make sure that we have the fuel that
we need
all right backing up systems clearing
unused accounts
uh guarding data in other ways are there
other things that you would mention
to say these are these are lessons that
are going to be important for the future
that obviously there was a gap a single
area of single vulnerability
other lessons you would mention yeah
thank you senator i i think from a
proactive standpoint you've seen now
where we brought mandian
in to to investigate as well as to
restore and start to harden our systems
but we talked a lot about standards in
this room today
and so we've also brought dragos in and
black hills in and people may ask
why is that overkill and i would say i
don't think so because what we want to
make sure is
we get the best out of each one of those
experts they all have a specific skill
drago is very good at ot systems right
we want to make sure that we have the
best hardening and the best segmentation
we can possibly have on our ot side
so i think again it's that that
investment in resources to get the best
in class because again
even the best in class is still
susceptible and we've heard that from
each one of those experts
right so if this is not ransomware
attack this is actually somebody that's
getting into the system
have you been able to determine going
through it whether they would be able to
get your operating system to be able to
change
pressure to be able to change volume to
be able to change flow
through the structure they actually came
through senator that's that's a great
question
obviously that factored in largely to my
decision uh
in the employee's decision to shut the
pipeline down that day
we didn't know and we probably didn't
know the answer to that for days the
investigation is ongoing but up to this
point
mandiant has not confirmed any evidence
that they were in the ot system
and typically that's not what darkseid
does right
right it's a different animal but it's a
vulnerability that sits out there for
someone else that uh
does mean to be able to do our nation
harm not just your company harm
at this point and if they're not just
going out for money but they're actually
going out for physical damage
thanks for being here thanks for being
so frank in your testimony thank you
senator
thank you uh senator langford senator
rosen you are
now recognized for your questions uh
thank you chairman peters ranking member
portman
uh this hearing of course so timely uh
so important and mr black uh thank you
so much
for spending your time with us today to
bring some clarity to these
extremely important issues to our nation
because you know what it's a challenge
for business owners across a variety of
industries to commit
the resources necessary in critical to
preventing and combating cyber threats
requires a team of dedicated staff with
cyber expertise and the technologies
needed
actually to defend against an attack
so mr blown it would be helpful to
understand the resources you have a
colonial pipeline devoted to cyber
security's technology personnel and
trainings
and so can you tell us just a bit about
uh your cyber guidelines and best
practices your
company follows do you collaborate with
federal agencies like nist
doe and cisa if you don't
um why not and um and just talk
to your plans to either current
collaboration or collaboration going
forward if you plan to do that
thank you senator for that very
important question we're a highly
collaborative organization
we're a highly transparent organization
we spend a lot of time in washington
at least up until covid and now we spend
a lot of time on the phone and
in zoom calls with with all our
regulators as well as other entities
like cisa
like the doe and other people that we
feel accountable to
uh for what we do uh for the nation so
again
very communicative uh very present in in
washington with all the federal agencies
that we have access to and we certainly
appreciate all the collaboration that
we're
able to do with them from a colonial
perspective you know we have over 100
people dedicated to i.t
our cio when she asks for funds related
to
anything associated with cyber she gets
it our board is highly supportive of
anything that protects the pipeline and
protects our data
so we've never had any issue from the
standpoint of getting the funding that
we
need in order to protect the asset and
protect our information and protect the
american public
thank you i want to kind of build on
this a little bit because according to
recent news reports
you have discussed scheduling a
voluntary
cyber security review with tsa a lot of
people have touched on this but that
review never
took place and so how often does your
company
conduct internal cyber security reviews
or self-assessments
you do this on a regular schedule and
what do you do with the results
who do you share them with or do you
share them senator thank you
thank you for that question with with
regard to the vadar
voluntary program the tsa has i i had
also heard in the press that we had
refused to participate in that and that
was quite a shock to me and
quite a shock to our cio we maintain a
lot of conversation with
with the tsa and specifically the
director of security level there
we have participated in a number of
things with the tsa in the past
including physical screening of our
facilities we have actually had the head
of tsa
in in our office meeting with me and my
management team
do you do your own internal reviews do
you share them with others how do you do
those on a regular
basis i guess that's also the point of
my my question
as well senator we we do participate in
in periodic penetration tests we do
auditing uh outside auditing of our
cyber procedures and our it department
in in like all audits you you you expect
you're going to find something with a
pace of change outside from the threat
and you rank the the the things that
come back
and then you go about the business of
tackling those those things that
they're deemed deficient or weak in
order to improve your defenses
so yes we do well you know i want to
build on that because you repeatedly
said during this hearing that
you weren't part of conversations in the
wake of the cyber attack
including the discussion with the fbi
about paying a ransom
in hindsight if you're doing these
analysis you're ranking things
doing all this what do you think you
should have been part of those
conversations senator that's a very good
question this was an all hands on deck
day in week my responsibility that week
was to communicate to my board
make sure that my team was communicating
where they needed to communicate
i directly handled all the discussions
at the doe level
including the daily briefings that we
did with the doe i participated in
briefing with the governor's offices
throughout the states that were impacted
so uh it while it'd be nice to be
involved in every conversation the
reality of it is
i i can't be every place at once but it
was well taken care of by any number of
my management team members the people
that report directly to me
thank you appreciate that i want to talk
a little bit about
my cyber sense act because we know of
course cyber tax is what's happened to
you so last congress i introduced the
cyber sense act as bipartisan
uh legislation that would create a
voluntary cyber sense program at the
department of energy that's going to
test the cyber security of products and
technologies
intended for use in our bulk power
system
uh this bill also directs the energy
secretary to consider
incentives to encourage the use of
analysis and testing results
when designing product products and
technologies although i think the
incentive would actually be not to be
hacked
but mr blunt while the program in my
bill would establish is solely for
electric
utilities do you think a similar program
for pipelines
would be helpful for gas companies like
yours across the board to collaborate
and communicate and have some
a sense of what's going on in the
industry senator thank you for that
question i i think that's a great
program for the electric utilities and i
think
anything that would help our side of the
business be more secure
and less susceptible to any threats is a
great idea
thank you and i think the last question
i have about a minute left i just want
to um
ask a quick question about uh why
colonial pipeline
didn't notify cisa immediately following
the ransomware attack mr wales told this
committee there uh
there's a benefit once assist is brought
in quickly because of the information we
glean we work to share in a broader
fashion to protect
other critical infrastructure so what's
your response to mr whale's statement
and um you're not sharing your ransom
uh where attack i'm glad you asked that
question senator
uh we one of the first phone calls we
made that morning within
hours of noticing the the compromise was
to the fbi office
and during that conversation with the
fbi the fbi said we will call you back
later we want to bring in our center of
excellence from california into the
conversation
and we will call sysa and bring them
into the conversation so at that point
based upon the number of phone calls
that we had to make that day to any
number of government governmental
entities we knew that cesa would be
notified and brought into the
conversation
we had a conversation with cesa the
first day as a result of that connection
with the fbi
if the fbi had not called them we would
have we called every other governmental
agency we were required to
and then some that day so again i i
don't know why he made that statement
but i can tell you
we would have called him there's no
reason not to we were extremely
transparent
and we wanted all the help that we could
get that morning
thank you very much for your testimony
today my times expired mr chairman
thank you senator rosen uh senator
hawley you are recognized for your
questions thank you mr chairman uh thank
you mr blunt for being here i think you
mentioned this in your your written
testimony but i'd just like to start
here what what percentage approximately
of all fuel
on the east coast of the united states
is transported by your company's
pipeline
thank you for that question senators
approximately 45 and how many gallons of
fuel does your company's pipeline
transport on a daily basis
normally on a we would move
approximately 100 million gallons of
fuel a day
senator yeah that's a lot is it fair to
say that
tens of millions of americans don't
really have any choice but to rely on
your your pipeline for fuel i mean you
have enormous market power is what i'm
driving at is that fair state senator
over time we've evolved as as a as a big
player in the fuel business and it's
because of our
our reliability record and quite frankly
we're the cheapest cost of
transportation for the fuel to those
customers yeah i think your pipeline i
think that the amount of fuel running to
the pipeline exceeds the fuel
consumption of germany
and if i'm not mistaken the closure of
your pipeline facilitated
uh nearly or or led to nearly 16 000
gas stations without fuel across the
country which is huge i mean
you're huge and consumers really rely on
you as my point
um i'm curious as to given this given
your market power given the the reliance
of consumers given the
the sheer number of consumers you serve
why didn't you take up the
transportation security administration's
offer to do a comprehensive cyber
security review of the pipeline
senator thank you for asking that
question we indeed were in contact with
them about
setting that up obviously coveted got in
the way in the early days of that
we were getting ready to move at the end
of the year into a new facility
so i think the conversation was that we
want to do it the vadar program is a
good program but we will schedule that
later on we do have that scheduled at
the end of july
so it was a covet issue basically or it
was a moving issue you're moving to a
new headquarters i'm looking at the
washington post article here that
that reports that uh the tsa had had
tried to
schedule a voluntary in-depth cyber
security review but that
the colonial just just couldn't get it
done do you regret not doing that in
retrospect
uh senator anything that you could do is
always helpful if we look at that test
it's a it's a great test but it's not
dissimilar to a lot of the
the tests that we already do in our
system again we have a good working
relationship with tsa
a little surprised by the statement that
i heard about refusal actually
investigated it on my end from my cio
and and their contacts on tsa side
no one really understood why the word
refused was used
so just so let me understand your last
summit are you saying you think that the
the tsa review would have been redundant
not particularly helpful
you said it's it's duplicative of things
you do on your own end internally
senator i think in this case it probably
wouldn't would not have resulted in
finding that legacy vpn again they don't
actually go into the system it's a
questionnaire format type thing i'm not
saying it wouldn't be valuable
it very much could be i think each one
of these tests are slightly different so
if there's just that one little piece
that can make the difference in seeing
something that's helpful again
never any issue with us actually getting
to the point of doing that it was a
timing issue
i got you who who owns colonial pipeline
only o
pipeline is owned by several entities
including
including uh a division of shell
midstream actually costly quebec kkr
ifm and koch industries got it i'm
asking that because
it's been reported that over the last
decade
colonial has distributed i'm looking at
the article here from bloomberg
colonials distributed almost all of your
profits sometimes more actually
in the form of dividends to your
investors in 2018 for instance colonial
pipeline paid 670 million dollars to its
owners which actually exceeded your net
income for that year but that that's a
pretty good return what
what do you invest in cyber security
every year
it's a great question senator we invest
over 200 million dollars over the last
five years in rit systems
and that's cyber security that's that
what how about on an annual basis for
cyber security 670 million dollars
distributed in
dividends in 2018 alone give me a sense
of
yeah you're operating not not unlike a
public utility right i mean we just we
covered the fact you serve
uh 45 50 of customers on the east coast
you transport 100 million gallons
a day you shut down your the attack on
you led to
16 000 gas stations being shut down so
just give me a sense of
given the importance of your company the
size of it the reliance
what are you doing in terms of your
investment for cyber security i know
you're paying your investors well
yeah senator great question our dividend
policy is not much different than any
other midstream company
so i want to i want to state that first
our our owners
have never denied us any opportunity to
spend what we need to spend in order to
keep the pipeline safe and secure which
is about what a year
you know take the average over 200
million dollars in the last five years
okay i'll tell you what we're 1.5
billion dollars in uh system integrity
every
every five years got it um i'd say we'll
give you this as a question for the
record so we can get the actual
i know you don't the number right in
front of you but we'll give you the
question for the record you can give us
the exact number on an annual basis i
think that would be interesting to know
you talk about federal regulations in
your testimony and you said congress
should consider designating an official
point of contact
at a federal agency to better facilitate
communication it's an interesting idea
what rules do you think congress ought
to consider requiring of
of you and your company i mean so that's
about your suggestion is what the
federal government should do of itself
but but given again your status
given the reliance on you what what do
you think congress ought to require of
of your company and companies like it
going forward senator great question i
i think what congress should require is
that we have a focus on safety and
security of this critical asset and i
think we've demonstrated that
over the last 57 years of responsible
ownership and operations
let me ask you a little bit about uh the
attack in the it system so i understand
that
the attack occurred or was diverse
detected only in the it network not in
the ot network is that right do i have
that correct editor that's correct okay
but the investigation shows up to this
point
got it okay so to your knowledge the ot
network the operational technology
network would not have been compromised
by the attack
if you hadn't have shut down you you
shut that down as a safe precaution
security measure senator if there was
one percent chance
that that ot system was compromised it
was worth shutting the pipeline system
down got it i'm just trying to establish
that
to your knowledge at this time you think
you think it was concentrated in the i.t
system senator based upon the
investigation by me got it to this point
that would be a correct statement yeah
okay so here this this leads me to ask
this i mean the pipeline is is
seven years old right roughly there was
a time i assume and you correct me if
i'm wrong but there's a time i assume
where you operated
the pipeline without today's computer
systems what i'm driving towards here is
do you have the capability to manually
operate
the pipeline in the event of in the
future in the event of an i.t attack
like this one
and if you don't have that capability
should you do you think going forward
senator that's a great question we
actually did operate small portions of
the pipeline manually in order to
alleviate some of the fuel shortage
and the discussion took place with the
operations team about the ability to do
that system-wide
and the response to that was it would be
quicker to get back up on our feet
by by correcting the corruption of the
critical i.t systems that we needed in
order to get the pipeline system up
then to operate it manually but i think
on a go forward basis
there's no question that we will look at
that capability
and it's a really interesting question
because if you look at the aging
workforce now
a lot of those people that did operate
colonial pipeline and other
infrastructure in america historically
manually they're retiring or they're
gone
fortunately we still have that last bit
of that generation which allowed us to
do what we did during this particular
event it's a great question yeah very
good thank you for being here thank you
mr chairman
thank you senator hawley senator ossoff
you are recognized for your questions
thank you mr chairman thank you as well
to ranking member portman mr blount
thank you for being here today thank you
for your candid testimony i want to
express my appreciation to
uh your team based in georgia for their
diligent efforts to restore
service swiftly and offer you the
opportunity before the committee now
uh to state any lessons learned
as well as reflections on potential
improvements to federal policy
that we haven't had a chance yet to
explore on the record and i
also want to thank you for your team's
uh continual updates of my team as you
sought to restore service as you've
investigated the nature of the threat
and for the conversation that you and i
have had uh uh about the matter as well
but lessons learned
recommendations for congress yeah uh
good morning senator mark you thank you
for your kind words too
yeah i think there are some several
really important lessons learned i think
you know the most important lesson
learned is to respond immediately
right and we've talked about stop work
authority
at colonial the ability to identify the
threat contain the threat remediate the
threat and restart the system and again
that goes towards any any type of threat
that we see
and not just particularly a cyber threat
so i think that's an important thing for
any operator to remember is
contain that threat the other side that
i'd like to share with you that i think
is extremely important is communication
and there's been a lot of conversation
in this room about who did you talk to
and who did you communicate
in in it and and what time did you do
that and again i i will stress again i
think that what we learned was that
being transparent and responding quickly
and not being afraid to come forward
was probably one of the most important
things that we did in this particular
case
not foreign to us but perhaps foreign to
others
and and finally i would add i think the
ability to communicate
with the federal government through one
conduit regardless of who it is
was extremely valuable to us because
again as i looked at this all hands on
deck
effort that we had to do the ability to
communicate
everything that we were seeing whether
it was the market response or the things
that we're trying to get done
on the it side to do the restart all the
way to the investigated
side of the equation extremely helpful
for a management team already stretched
to be able to communicate
quickly and efficiently and then allow
our government partners to do what they
could do to help us
which indeed they did they were very
helpful in the process
thank you mr blount as you and i
discussed last week
your team i believe in collaboration
with mandiant is conducting a
comprehensive review of
the threat the nature of the attack uh
what might have been done to mitigate
the risk that
the uh efforts to thwart the attack once
it was discovered is that correct
yes senator that's correct and what
impediment would there be if any to
uh sharing the results of that review
and the conclusions of that
investigation including at the technical
level
with this committee once it's completed
senator i don't think there's any issues
with that what we've been trying to do
all along the way is share the
information as we learn it
we've been very straightforward about
the legacy vpn hopefully that will help
out other operators who have similar
type
legacy assets we know from working with
mandia that's not an unusual issue
for companies so again i think we'll
continue to communicate as we go through
the process with mandate
but our ability and desire to sit down
with you is is ready and available
when you would like that great so we we
can expect that once that
review and investigation are complete uh
that that you'd voluntarily share with
this committee the results of mandiant's
investigation
yes senator we'll be very transparent
appreciate that when you and i spoke
last week i believe you
stated that you had not refused any
requests for information
from the department of homeland security
the fbi
or other federal entities you've
discussed the importance of the free
flow of information
between the target of an attack like
this
and the federal government having now
had the experience of
your company being subjected to an
attack such as this
and the communication that you had to
engage in swiftly with federal entities
what do you think can be done to improve
and make more efficient and direct the
flow of information
between the victim of a cyber attack
and federal law enforcement federal
cyber security authorities and i want to
drill down a little bit on the following
you and i also discussed last week that
the criminal enforcement side
of the investigation and the cyber
security side
of the investigation overlap but are
also distinct
have you found any difference in the
quality of the federal response
the nature of your communication with
federal authorities between the
criminal prosecutorial investigation and
the cyber security investigation
senator i i from my perspective i would
say the answer is no
and again as we discussed we had fbi
cesa and of course mandy and helping in
the process right and we told mandiat
from the very beginning if the fbi had
questions or
cesa had questions please share
information with them and then
of course uh as structured by the white
house we had the ability to communicate
with everybody else on the restoration
side and on the supply concern
inside through the doe and again that
worked wonderfully
wonderfully for us again our our time
was stretched during the day when we're
trying to respond to the situation and
get things
remediated so that we can bring the
pipeline back up so from my perspective
as the ceo to sit
down at least at five o'clock every day
and sometimes more often
phone calls would come but at least we
have the ability to communicate the
restoration side what we were doing to
restore the it systems
share market market intelligence because
we have a unique perspective
uh as colonial uh as well that was very
helpful so regardless of who that
conduit is
the ability to communicate on the
investigative side
with all those parties at once and on
the
restoration and the market side
extremely valuable to us
there's a as you can imagine there's a
lot going on
as you head towards bringing an asset
like this back up and you've got a lot
of people that want to know a lot of
things
and you don't have all the answers yet
but what i found is by having them all
in the same room
the expert on this one particular area
would say they wouldn't know that yet
and that would alleviate a lot of
concern that the less knowledgeable
person might have even though they were
very strong in what their particular
discipline or science was thank you mr
blount and finally circling back to the
ongoing
mandiant investigation can you commit
that the product that you share with
this committee
of that investigation will be the same
product that you and your
executive team and your board review and
that it won't be uh
a different set of conclusions um that
are produced for
the consumption of of congress but it'll
be that the same assessment that you
receive
senator as i stated uh previously we
will be very transparent
i think the one thing that we need to be
careful about as a nation is
how do we share that information
obviously would be very difficult in a
public forum like this because a lot of
what we'll share about our strengthening
and hardening of our systems
will be critical to keeping those strong
and defensive
against attacks but yes we we need to
talk and figure out what's the best way
to talk about what happened
as well as what best practice on a
go-forward basis is for an operator like
ours that operates such
sensitive infrastructure so recognizing
that some of those conclusions
information and plans may be sensitive
and confidential
nevertheless the appropriate forum for
those confidences
being provided we'll be able to exchange
that information freely in review and
full demanding report
senator we gladly cooperate with you
thank you mr blount and
i yield back mr chairman thank you
senator
ossoff well mr mom i would like to uh
thank you
for joining us here this morning on this
incredibly
important manner you know we are clearly
experiencing
uh relentless uh and unprecedented
assaults
against both our private and public
sector
information systems and we're getting
those assaults by both criminal
organizations
as well as foreign adversaries and this
is a grave
national security concern and certainly
from the questions that were posed today
by
all of my colleagues i think it's clear
that my colleagues believe this is
something that
we need to address immediately and in a
comprehensive
fashion it's clear to me that the cyber
attack against
colonial highlights the need for
increased cooperation and coordination
between
both the federal government and our
critical infrastructure
partners we must ensure that the
american people are
capable of not only defending our
critical infrastructure partners from
attack but also maintaining
a secure information system environment
to prevent those cyber attacks from
occurring in the first place the
infrastructure that american lives
depend
on is increasingly connected connected
to each other
and connected to the internet this
brings a whole new meaning to the phrase
you're only as strong as your weakest
link
and these weak links can be hacked
accounts inadequate passwords
or unknown vulnerabilities to the system
uh more must be done in this pace
in this space and i'm committed to
certainly focusing my attention
i think every member on this committee
agrees that this committee
will focus our collective attention and
resources
on dealing with this problem cyber
attacks uh
used to be merely an inconvenience we
now
know that they're becoming attacks on
our very way of life
uh once again thank you for appearing
here today i look forward to your
continued
engagement on this important issue
the record for this hearing will remain
open for 15 days until
june 23rd at 5 00 pm for submission
of statements and questions for the
record and with that this hearing
is now adjourned
hello
thank you so much i appreciate it
thank you so much
well
yes
it's